Jim yeah turn around to your right and
put this in a more inconvenient TV this
is where the TV video right there
it's this is the one that's plugged in
right if you have to use another
microphone you can use another
microphone but complainers don't get any
help complainers don't get any dessert
okay
yes we do where's the controller so we
have Red Dead Redemption - in studio we
were talking about this yesterday and I
remember we were talking about it
yesterday cuz a lot of people on Twitter
got upset that I was saying Oregon Trail
apparently everything Oregon
oaragaintrail
gives a [ __ ] its Oregon Trail yeah Oh
Reagan gives a [ __ ] Reagan Oh Trail
Travis did you have any problem with the
way it pronounced - Oregon Trail a lot
do you see a lot of people did [ __ ] them
yeah follow the hole there's no there's
no cord are you impressed with the
wireless controller yeah probably delay
but it's not as no delay it's been like
that for years okay so where we were
playing Red Dead - Travis and I've been
playing it all weekend it's a great new
game from rockstar games
Lazlo sent it over and we were
describing it to Jim and it's a little
bit complicated so we were wondering
exactly how Jim would do Travis which
rank you gonna talk do I hit that do I
hit player
no do I play hit the circle button but
where I put the white which one is white
okay Jim is - hang on before we start
Jim is trying to figure out how to get
off the pause screen no no but I mean do
I hit social club settings story player
I'm telling you hit the hit the circle
button here circle oh no oh my god as
you can hear he's back on the home
screen yeah he's okay we're play okay
now Jim's characters in Red Dead - I'm
gonna walk over here
Jim is playing a cowboy walking over to
the no three stops okay Jimmy asked you
to give him some space what are you
gonna do he's gonna keep while he's
gonna give him some space okay good for
you Jim now what this sucks
he's just walking around in circles yeah
turn around all I can see it different
angle good I can see his hat Jim is Anna
is that her
it's a go but if you look to where
you're walking he's on the side of a
river do you want your horse or go
horseback riding yeah it was the [ __ ]
horse don't don't do it for him Travis
okay oh [ __ ] he's getting his ass kicked
by a guy he just he just opened the log
I don't know
Travis do not hit those buttons farm
he's back on the home screen mother [ __ ]
back in the log he's getting punched in
the face hitting every button boom the
[ __ ] face taken by the way it says
what back is on the stream so there's no
reason we're in the bottom right corner
of the screen back he's the circle you
just he didn't hit the circle okay he's
back he's in his ass man punch yeah yeah
he's back in the log scream now he's at
oh he's choking him he's choking him Jim
is choking this stranger oh my god
Jim the directions are in the lower
corner I decided shut up I'm choking on
the eyeball did you kill him how do I
pull my gun out Ludum loot him Louie oh
my god Jim just killed a man how do I go
down how I loot him it says right there
down triangle okay loot him oh he's
picking him up instead he's carrying the
body I call Jim just killed a man Jim
you're pretty good at this game Jim just
killed a stranger is this wrong with my
kickers heart okay now he's walking into
the river now what do I do with this
body how do I drop the body well there
you go
you threw the body in the river get my
ID the evident oh good bye [ __ ] off okay
cool
how do I suck the horses dick all right
hop on now
okay Jim it okay it says right now get
back here here take a look in that horse
[ __ ] okay we're careful you know
jumping the fire who cares
come on move the camera you move the
camera we're with you want to see his
butt okay he's back in the log screen
all right let's see it move the camera
yeah there you go okay he's going up and
down and set aside to side there we go
look at that horse dick he got to a
camera shot up between the horse's legs
all right now he's turning around here
dad get back come on [ __ ] now the camera
he's got a horse tail stupid
he's got an aerial shot now I'm still oh
great it's the end of the [ __ ]
alright the I'm looking in a row lair
which right now how do I jump up on this
stupid I lost the C's peanuts again does
yes I do he does and yes alright what
he's standing in front of the horse now
okay no yeah I'll here it is can you get
on the horse
looks like you're having a lid so he's
on the horse yeah Jim is on the horse
let's go for don't okay it looks like
area is he's walking on the side of the
river how do you [ __ ] speed up
already it's a horse
I mean how fast you want it to go pick
it up see Winona you know you can play
hold on okay got off the horse I just
want the how could he punch any punch
the horse okay okay now he's standing
next to the horse get back over there
come on you can't get back on the horse
now I'm a [ __ ] horse standing next to
him there is let's go boy and now
they're going actually you can tell him
you can tell him Travis because the key
commands aren't popping you can double
tap and hold X to speed up just beat up
there you go now we're moving we're
galloping oh now listen to that music
Jim is galloping across the great
landscapes of what state would you say
this is Travis in New York really nope I
guess upstate maybe I like the Palisades
alright cool this is over by the by the
outlet
it's like Nyack yeah I see yeah nice
come on [ __ ] it what are you doing okay
oh great you're steering the horse
alteration I hate the horse just walked
into a tree don't [ __ ] horse you
never kill my horse
you're galloping we're do it freeze he's
stupid are you going just keep moving
right he's up on the hill what you're
gonna do
where do you want to go are we going
this game is dumb [ __ ] all right go
right once I look there's animals around
good alright now how long should I do
this for as long as you want that's the
whole point it's an open-world game here
in the why
wild west all right let's go up try to
kill these Jim West in this game right
no wrong way oh wait [ __ ] okay you're
walking into a rock Jim okay you're
walking your horse directly into a giant
rock and I'll go up the hill okay that's
it
it would appear you are not going up the
hill you're going in circles like a
[ __ ] horse doesn't obey commands
you're making the horse chase its tail
now he's going to run up the hill okay
let's see let's see the horse in Red
Dead Redemption - running up the hill
where this horse really runs even now
yeah you weren't hitting ax dude got a
double tap and hold X I'm holding it of
course he does okay okay we're going ot
it's very very steep so some B's I'm
going down the [ __ ] Hill the horse
almost the horse almost toppled over
because the hill was so steep Jim I
think is having a fun time okay Travis
isn't strumming the weeds
Travis is instructing Jim to keep on the
the trail come on [ __ ] that's there in
the wild wild west he's got his gun out
you're going inside shoot the horse
alright I'll bet you good where's the
[ __ ] trail lost I see right on the man
yeah yeah she's so hard not to help it's
the thing that looks like a trail yet do
not help try no it's it's just in my
instinct he's never gonna learn if you
help him I got a text from Jess that
said be nicer to Jim thank you she's
right Jim am i doing a bad job of
instructing yeah you are the horse is
going in circles I hate these
controllers you really think so ok here
we go
except lavinia complete opposite
direction of the way did he turn himself
around
well you're not following the red line
what's at the red line
oh yeah the red line I'll take you
somewhere right yeah trying to follow
the red line you went in the red line
and collect a debt from somebody you're
going in a sea you're going in circles
check I would like to see you kill
somebody you did that very easily
yeah choke the guy to death really that
was an awesome especially since he was
trapped in the log screen after getting
punched in the face a bunch of times all
right looks like we're done walking in
circles for the moment and are we
following yeah we're following the red
line that's good stuff yep there we go
now we're galloping across the landscape
just how do you spend hours doing this
[ __ ] are you getting my waste of time
jerking off hey getting bored already
it's not boring it's frustrating kill I
don't know how to use the control I mean
part of it is that I don't spend most of
my time just walking my horse around in
a circle I see oh good a rabbit can I
step on the rabbit how do you know it's
the I mean the horse theoretically
you've got a bow and arrow that you can
hunt things my way you're not galloping
yes I do
poor Jim made the horse jump a moment
ago yeah I think you're figuring out
these controllers there yeah so the old
Chris Reeve tribute [ __ ] made the horse
jump he's hoping to paralyze his cowboy
I'm now just a wild horse I got a wild
stallion good yeah you're not doing a
good job of taming it I have to be
honest okay you're going do you really
think so yeah he's at a horse
I'll bet he's back on the home screen
that is one of the great sounds for
radio is the sound of Jim going back to
the homes I truly don't know what I'm
doing
go see now I'm going straight he's going
crooked well I don't think so that's
like whether your dad said about you
[Laughter]
there he goes he's galloping now oh you
got wild horses they couldn't keep him
away good okay how do you shoot him can
I talk to him hey which one is shooting
yeah okay oh I didn't know these were
buttons okay you just found the r1 r2 l1
l2 keys that's good shot the grass
you're shooting nothing you got a point
the gun in his direction I'm gonna have
another bounty on my head yeah yeah okay
Jim is just in an open field shooting
into the ground
do you like shooting Jim I love it
where's the guy okay let's see where did
he go we've lost sight on our target
we're now back into an aerial aerial
view hiding we're limiting our view yeah
Jim you miss Timmy he's in the distance
he's not in the sky Jim Jim has the
camera pointed to the sky where is he
there he is riding away in the bin the
background or in the foreground I guess
that is okay you're walking in circles
that's a minute okay you're going in the
wrong direction you're just firing the
gun at the grass and you do not have
unlimited bullets by the way big deal
how do I get them you gotta move your
horse toward him I guess right now your
back is to him and he's been riding for
quite a while Troy how do you think
Jim's doing that's good right okay seems
to be going in the wrong direction again
am i I'm gonna guess that that guy might
have officially gotten away okay I just
stepped on a deer it's a dead deer
that's him that's the guy I shot him you
know what to do no you didn't shoot him
he shot the grass you didn't shoot
anywhere near the guy
okay Jim is walking in circles again
this is good stuff trying to the [ __ ]
horses you try operating on a mechanical
horse it's a wild horse isn't it that's
right where that wasn't you you just
waiting for the guy to get to you that's
actually kind of smart
Jim is turning around now oh there's a
guy Oh No
why did shootin water he's shooting you
Jim oh you shot and killed he killed you
dude why cuz you were shooting the water
I did you want to have another go at it
I think you should he gets another go
right really bad at this that's his
first time Travis okay he's back on the
home screen I'm walking again you lost
your horse bro oh no no he's in first
person this is not good I can't get
about a first person you can't know
you're back at you yeah I didn't know
you could even go into first person in
this game Jim Jim do you like
first-person better more difficult to
manage isn't it actually not like you do
okay you get to look at the landscape a
little better what are you shooting at
dude showing everybody I'm walking hey
stay away from me no I know no but you
got to go up to it I'm trying to aim
where okay okay let's see he's walking
up he's just walking up to a guy and
pointing his gun at him this is the most
hostile there you go you shot him he's
not dead dude you did shoot
he's gonna be pissed he shot his board
going you shot him in the horse his
horse is dead
you better shoot him he's gonna be so
pissed got him nope he's still alive
yeah he's still alive shoot up dude you
gotta aim am I so happy I shot his dumb
horse you killed his horse man stupid
horse
you killed trauma in my land yeah you
killed his horse what do you think of
the game it's great I mean it's not yeah
I could understand why people would love
that I I won't take the Travis can you
maybe put him in it in a different
scenario I just got a text
tony burton says this is elder abuse i
can bring him to like valentine how long
did that take
don't take a minute okay bring into
Valentine let's you don't think I can
get to Valentine myself yeah let's have
Travis speed this up a little bit all
right
okay Travis is gonna head you to
Valentine he's gonna open up the map and
he's gonna bring you to the town that's
like how does that sound Jim I'd love to
go to the town you wouldn't have a
beverage yeah
yeah see I know how to get to Valentine
you would've been able to get there
right yeah I want just go have a
beverage I'm parched
were you happy that you shot that horse
oh my god watch that [ __ ] dumb horse
laughter the guys jump off it cuz guess
what even though the guy shot you he's
got a walk now I don't know [ __ ] mr.
oh look if someone's going through the
trees
yeah looks like Travis isn't that good
is he Travis you're going to the Mike
don't can hear you Travis nobody can
you're treating and you're in the trees
you're terrible at this game yeah turn
around
Jim how bad it's don't unplug it back in
well hot dog had to help him Jim didn't
get hot dogs help Travis is not that
good you seem going in circles when he
was in first person it is hard to make
the horse go straight well now actually
Travis seems to have no problem with it
are you John are you adjusted as he goes
yeah
were you not doing that yeah were you
not adjusting as you went it was buried
off the trail mmm
Travis is staying on trail a little
better than you or I have to be honest
yes but he can't do first-person well
you sucked it kill them once you kill
the person because he's going to
Valentine but he's also I'll tell you
this Travis is not good at radio while
he's playing oh yeah he's literally as
back as to the mic
may look at the man long now shoot these
people maybe some because he cares about
the audience how do you take the gun out
get off pull the gun out yeah are you
learning as you go hey you go why you
kill them your aim stinks yeah I didn't
kill him
no you shot away Travis you're you're
terrible at this game you scared your
horses to what oh shoot the kids okay
there's people Travis just side or shot
a wagon full of people yeah there's
another witness Travis there's a lady
running a ring Amish lady she's shooting
Amish people okay Travis you're an awful
shot he is eight times you hit her she's
like the Godfather shot says she's still
alive some lady in the Old West falls
off a wagon you have to shoot her eight
times before she died up what a great
game who are you to criticize Jim yeah
you suck Wow the whole town you're
shooting exactly every time you shoot
you a lamb shoot the [ __ ] sheep aha
Travis went to the most pop ah
somebody's choking him to death oh he's
hitting back Travis is hitting back but
he's lost his hat that's not good yeah
get your hat a lot of people on the
internet we're complaining that every
time they play this game and they leave
to go someplace they come back and they
don't know where they've placed their
hat I don't know what their hat
everybody loses their hat in this game
yeah go get your hat Travis you can't
try to silence witnesses in the most
populated area of the game it's going
that create more witnesses Times Square
try to quiet everybody
yeah you better just leave dude where's
your horse she scared it away great now
you're just running with a muddy back
right why is this back muddy look he's
been taking dick in the barn okay
there's the horse you better get the
[ __ ] out of here Travis you're trying to
show Jim how to play all you're showing
us is that you exactly know what you're
going through the are they chasing you
yeah they are as good off a cliff cliff
Travis you keep getting shot I kind of
like this you do yeah ah Travis sucks
now it's Jim Stern now I love it okay
Jim now you're like that I love it I'll
get you back over there and do that yeah
yeah let's go to the town let's go to
the town and watch Jim just create a
massacre in the wild wild west do you
like the idea of doing that I do
creating a massacre in the West anything
is you have to remember that now there's
a bounty on my head so when I go into
Valentine there are people looking for
me so you got to be ready
she always equipment he does what's up
Joe Joe you there Joe I can hear you you
should be able to hear I can't hear Joe
I mean I can hear the static oh I can
hear that his phone's on maybe falsely
maybe he did I wouldn't blame him he's
going back to Travis is gonna bring the
horse back to was that Valentine you
were in Travis now that was Valentine
okay what a lousy coward sucked there
was nothing there bunch of [ __ ] sheds
okay Jim's got the controller back this
is what I is what I paid good money to
see yep don't bring your gun to town boy
leave your gun at home oh boy there's
only seven bullets
Travis you would have set him up to fail
Oh oh no he's back up shoot him again
Jim shoot him again shoot him again okay
I think he got him all guys back up oh
boy reported boy he murdered a guy of
course the crime was reported horse jump
run over him sure why not he's a dead
body now horse is running over him oh
you're shooting the townspeople right in
the back right in the back like so
Howard stop whining so I'm just trying
to rat you out Travis what's the code
for more bullets you don't got a game
genie in this you got to go to the
general store and buy one ball where's
the general store I can get you another
gun now you want another gun go to the
general
no we got shot in the head somebody's
shooting him in horses panicking you
casually walking well the horse I hit
the button and the horse wouldn't go I
have to be honest Jim [ __ ] stupid
horse you did not move with any any
speed or urgency I hit the button the
horse just stood there like a dick
Travis can you please load up Jim with
some ammunition and I mean a lot Jim
needs to show up with depend on how much
money I have we'll use it all on
ammunition how do I go into the general
store you can I can't you get the best
low rate you can get online and go to
the general and save some time why are
you running Travis is in a rush
okay go to the generalized or exactly
hey Shelley she owes at least you can
play the game and talking to a
microphone yeah then again radio has
never been Travis's forte that's right
he's here for provisions
bullets please thank you I immediately
the Denny Falcone of store owners I
don't need the conversation just give me
a ton of bullets I'd like to spend all
my money on bullets please
okay ammunition what can you get Travis
what do you got money for I have about
$25 I seem to remember I had about 90
when the game start yeah $25 saw wanna
buy wears bullets I want to buy bullets
yeah and what else what else do you
think you need they're in the Wild West
Jim more bullets I have a think about it
Travis he said he said you sold out of
bullets
he sold out of bullets what general
stores you go to Travis who doesn't have
bullets do you talked into thin air
he's not even talking into a microphone
is he Jim no just looking foolishly you
know what that's why it 60 is 60 bullets
okay what's the adoption up no it's not
okay you're right it's not okay 120 it
is 120 bullets 120 bullet get me some
bullets
[Laughter]
Mike in Connecticut has a tip what's up
Mike
hey guys I love this man I loved it from
the first time to have Jim put on his
bandana and fight out it on feet on his
feet so he can walk over bodies and pick
up ammo that seems like a lot right now
for Jim to tell you the truth Mike I did
it I remember on the train mission I did
that seems like a lot your gun is drawn
in there a lot of people around oh boy
Jim brought his gun to town there's also
horses if you'd like to shoot them
horses take big shits in this game have
you seen that yeah I have somebody
somebody I saw a video somebody posted
hello our aim there are people that are
just sitting around any reason yeah
people want to know Jim any reason you
got your gun drawn people are so naive
yeah there you go
one bullet took a guy the guy who looked
at you and said hey guys your gun drawn
just took a lead of a bullet right in
the head man did that guy eat lead Jim
you just shot a guy in the middle of the
forehead how do you feel phenomenal come
on go around the pole [ __ ] there's a
bounty on you people are so pissed Oh
shot another guy in the head Jim you're
a good shot all right you're dead but
you shot two people in the head I'd say
that's a major accomplishment yeah I
have to tell you guys something those of
you listening at home Jim had a scowl on
his face
the whole time he was riding horse there
is an ear-to-ear grin a tooth east a
Cheshire Cat toothy smile is appearing
on Jim's face never die right in the
chin right in the chin that uppercut it
if I don't have one neither will hey
blue is a face-off
all right cool now you just go sit in
the water okay wash up a little bit I'm
gonna get you back to the town no I try
to hang on the water yeah nice cool dip
in the water cool dip in the water
shooting some people in the head let's
go to Freddy swim you're gonna go for a
swim
don't you worry the currents gonna take
you away no I hope it does this is fun
you like that you like swimming Jim like
swimming and he like shooting oh of
course she is that's all right he's
looking at the wildlife swimming Jim
you're having a good time
I
I sure AM you would love to Oregon Trail
let's go to Fred in the Bronx what's up
Fred you know via the Hat know how I am
cuz it does appear that Jim oh hang on
thread Jim has lost his hat however he
found a guy in the water crossing on a
horse and he'd like to shoot him would
you like to shoot that guy dad more than
I want to breathe now look over to him
he hasn't done anything do you gotta use
both of those I don't know what I'm
doing you the other one does the camera
that's okay you're getting better Jim
looks like you've lost the guy yeah
unfortunately there is a bounty on your
head yeah for $215 why all the murder is
that that we did previously yep yeah
yeah okay no water this day he's trying
to go fishing I guess with his gun okay
your get your now I would have it would
seem that you've lost interest in
swimming because you've gotten excited
about shooting yeah oh good Andrew try
your hand drew I'm glad you're here I'm
glad you're here you can see this for
yourself
Jim is playing Red Dead Redemption too
he's not exactly a gamer Andrew okay
yeah he's not exactly a game what the
[ __ ] I'm doing he has learned how to
shoot people and he's super super happy
about it it's a cowboy game Andrew yes
yes and it's not necessarily
first-person there's a first-person mode
but you get to run around the wild wing
in the weeds are you hiding so you can
sneak up on somebody get them I'm
jerking off of the weeds
Andrew Jim just figured out how to kill
people and when I tell you in the in the
two-plus years in the 25 months that
we've been doing a show together I don't
think I've ever seen Jim's smile bigger
then when he figured out he could just
walk up to a guy and shoot him in the
head dead
yeah welcome to childhood bro that's
what he did he walked out but he was in
the town I love how you guys signed a
contract yesterday and now you're
playing video games on yeah exactly what
are they gonna do I don't know what do
you what do you want Travis anymore
people we know what he wants to do just
want to run so he walked up to a guy in
want to be free he's running like the
daughter fall they're all fun oh yeah
he's shooting you don't shoot the wrong
horse why did you shoot the rock I don't
know I just got excited
kill them
you shot between the horse's legs I
wanted to kill the horse are you done
yeah all right so actually you know what
Travis one more time cuz I want to see I
want show you I'm gonna take him to
Valentines take him to a town so that at
least Schultz can see how happy he gets
I don't I can't aim I don't know how to
aim what my idea of the game can we
break that or did ya of it like it's a
hole there's like Travis it it's like a
65 our story right that you go on and
basically the premise is it's at the end
of the Old West West world America is
started whether or not robots there
people right America is one will see I
mean American make someone a person oh
yeah I watched the last season you're
right let's get it you like it not the
last one yes what's that yeah so the
idea is that this is a gang of Outlaws
and America is is modernizing and
they're kind of on the run and trying to
avoid all this modern technology that is
now looking to catch them and go through
crimes and make money and do all that
jump off but it's like it's like Grand
Theft Auto in the sense that there's all
these missions that you go on but really
after you do a few missions what you end
up doing is opening up the whole world
and then you can just go around and have
fun and shoot people and watch the horse
[ __ ] and like look at its balls and
stuff like that
that's really all we want to do right I
mean they put them they put why else
would you have the horses testicles in
the game yeah cuz you want to look at
those balls you want to look at the
horses balls and people are having a
blast looking at horse balls you're
dirty how do you clean your dumb horse
probably jump in that water the water
Travis is gonna do
he will alway bucked you right off he
said [ __ ] you Travis I'm not going in
that water them disobedience [ __ ] horse
Jim wanted we were trying to make Travis
walk the horse off a cliff and the horse
wouldn't do it so you can't get your
horse to jump let's see oh we're going
down a very steep hill off the horse and
the horse fell down boy it was fine
Jim what's funnier to you watching the
guy take a header or watching the horse
tumble watching both of them like clumsy
[ __ ] I'm loving this
you know like I don't know if it's
parents are many people our age when we
find out that people watch other people
play video games right first people
watch it yeah how stupid I'm sitting
here going people listen to other people
play video games but you walked into
this room going I can't believe they're
doing this and within 30 seconds
enthrall you're in you're totally in you
just started you just started going like
I mean it's amazing Mary Ann and North
Carolina has a request
Lebanon Mary Ann you need to punch the
horse ok punt your Travis we have a
request from a listener that you punched
that horse how do you predict in the
face by a horse all attack the horse
left if you don't punch it again you're
fired
[Laughter]
now you're I've been watching your face
this is great and some of this you're
like I don't know why the [ __ ] we're
doing this anyway but now that you're
seeing Travis punch that horse funny
you're on board right ok good alright so
trav how do you punch that's all I want
to do is punch my horse
okay Jim's back to the controllers he's
walking towards the horse now this is
Jim playing and he's gonna Jim just
punched his horse in the side of the
neck and and then the horse kicked him
in his neck and killed him
I'm gonna have to rebuild the trust of
my horse my ass was that worth it Jen
all boy wasn't was that great punching a
horse in the kill bike well the horse
killed him
yes it did why did the words kill him he
punched it in the side of the neck I
didn't know that was possible
isn't it amazing what you can do in
these games yeah they just think of
everything for you because there's no
mission that you would ever need to
punch your own horse like that's no
reason but they knew you'd want to yeah
well of course they knew somebody would
want to punch their horse the oats a
great pitch meeting to be in do we need
should we make it visually make
functionality that allows the user to
punch the horse absolutely why doe why
would you punch the horse for pleasure
for pleasure mainly for the head is so
big and punchable well I've never
punched a horse before and I've always
kind of wanted to it's a female horse
not to that's a dick I think it's just
not erect right now can you get the
horse erect ahead can you punch his dick
see if you can duck between the horse
Travis smacked it on the end the horse
in the face Travis beating just abusing
your horse they're going you make me run
across the Wild West and now you just
keep punching me in the face can you get
on the back and punch the back of his
head okay yeah Travis can you find out
for me I'll check the poor horse walks
back yeah he just winds up and just just
clocks it yeah you finally get his trust
back he's like all right I [ __ ] up and
then it's like okay alright you know
everything's fine
he's walking behind me now he's probably
gonna load up or whatever I say just
push it it's [ __ ] up shelf can you
believe this is with the children of
America are doing right now this is it
in the PC culture that we live in you
can't say anything about anybody
cultures fault right I can't say
anything about anybody but you can go
home
you tried to make him any three down a
[ __ ] Hill and you died the horse got
sick at Travis trying to make him jump
off cliffs so he bunked Travis right off
a cliff but if I was if I was 13 or 15
I'd be out of my mind for this you can I
would literally I played asteroids for
you know [ __ ] hours every day this I
would I would never never stop lying
never I wouldn't in sell you wouldn't
masturbate as much as you do now if you
just had this when you were a kid yeah
why was there some drama over this game
there was some protest I think was there
yeah
well cuz there was an article about how
hard or in how long maybe some people
worked on the game with the the owner or
the the the head of rockstar yeah I kind
of made an offhanded comment that like
you know we worked a hundred hour weeks
and so people were protesting that
you're getting paid for 100 hour weeks
you should be working that much in that
a great role model in that a great
example to set for people you should
only work eight hours a day and then you
should rest always rest people should be
working on hundred hours of different
horse i don't know where my horse won
your horse my weight can quit yet it's
bruised and beaten you train in time you
treated your horse in the game like we
treat [ __ ] loaf on the show no wonder he
doesn't like us
[ __ ] loves it [ __ ] love is just trying
to find a cliff to buck us off down
let's punch the horse that's a beautiful
organ so Travis is down by the river now
Travis is the goal right now to get back
to a town so Jim can shoot okay
and you have another horse how do you
eat and look like that to me I think you
might have been right go back to that
let's go fishing
yeah let's get some fish punch the fish
yeah oh you got to do that I didn't know
this thing what do you do there's all
kinds of [ __ ] that you'll never be able
to learn Jim don't even worry about a
brother why don't you shoot the fish
with the bow and arrow
yeah but when you shoot it with a bullet
it's quicker yeah
I mean you only get one shot fish tend
to swim away after you know that we're
gonna [ __ ] nail this you know I think
so no horse can you shoot it out with
your horses balls
if teenage Jim found out you could shoot
your horse at the balls would you ever
do anything different it's all I would
do they shoot that horse's dick and
balls from under it I would lay under it
and shoot up at his dick and balls
that's all thirteen year old Jim with
you look it's worth doing 100 hours a
week to play a game although I can't
spend a hundred hours a week I don't get
it
yes you be intelligence company that
long as you want they're probably people
taking you back to town okay probably
people feel very passionate about video
games that want to put out something
amazing right how long do you work a
week you must work more than 40 hours
yeah no well it's all work when I'm
watching wrestling I do rest that's true
that's works for you thank you why isn't
it working
yeah you got a huge sports podcast now
here we go every game works
you have to yeah I bet I could write
that off of course you can write it off
again definitely write kidding me I
should get that NBA package yeah you
should NFL package your patreon people
need you to talk about oh here the
Lakers yeah yeah Diddy you like it dude
that [ __ ] that was crazy man I have to
tell you something I've been tracking
flagrant twos progress on patreon
it's unbelievable okay we're doing well
I'll tell you this
Schultz tried to make it classy by
editing out the amount of money that
they were bringing in it's actually not
true
I leave it right there I thought Cass
was the one that leaves it in no Cass
wants to Cavs want to take it out but I
leave it right there because I think
people who are like supporting you they
want to know that you got the biggest
[ __ ] and how do you know we don't
support you you want them to know that
you got the biggest [ __ ] number is
because there's like those two big
podcasts yeah what are they Chapo's Trap
House and then calm down calm down yeah
right and tell them Steve Davis pretty
big soon okay yeah but they have patreon
the only reason I've heard anyone talk
about that
uh-huh this because how much the
patriotic right so I'm like if it's
making money let us use your right and
if it's not making money hide it nobody
don't nobody knows
we've talked anyway okay I'm sorry for
the distraction all extracting audio in
the background 100 percent sure we're
not on the air
Jim is shooting people in balance Jim is
where are the people they're already
shooting you now oh geez I trying to
hide you got shot in the neck
did you shoot anybody you didn't kill
anybody did you shot one guy eight times
you die so much work to do later John in
New Jersey what's up John hey can't you
bring Jim to like the saloon or
something and find miss penny in the
back you know give him a little rubber
indifference to him I'll watch you I
don't want to play are their Wild West
hookers in it Travis do we not know I
haven't but I know where the saloon is
you know why Travis is not a good
producer because we bring in this game
to do a bit and Travis is clearly more
invested in the game than the fact that
we're playing it on the air yes yes he'd
like you forget that there's even a
microphone once he gets the controller
he's enjoying smiling to himself right
now he likes it yeah I love playing this
game it's [ __ ] great did Jim screw up
your progress oh yeah best game best
game ever this one yeah that's too early
to tell best game I mean I've only
played it for like three or four hours
oh this just came out over the weekend
there was a lines up in at the what's
ago at Gamestop yeah yeah yeah couldn't
get it I met on Friday is it sold out no
it's online you can download it so why
would people even go into the game stop
I don't know maybe get into like
physical copies for what to resell you
can't resell a digital copy once you're
done with it I guess that's true and
also there's there's places like like
Best Buy has like a gamers club where
you pay 20 bucks and you get 20% off for
like two years are you in the gamers
Club of course I am [ __ ] dork kind of
merger thank you
so uh you get to wear a sash like when
you were on the safety patrol yes I'm
here I mean the gamers now we're we're
uh how much is this game 60 bucks that's
not bad that's how much our games are
for the most 16 yeah it's a bargain
think about how many hours you play this
yeah it's great right I mean think about
how much fun you just had only in a
little bit moderate amount of fun dude
I'm done I saw you smiling I I did enjoy
it for a minute if Travis brought you
back your Tommy you don't kind of want
to now explore Valentine and maybe shoot
some people know because I stink at it I
hate this little circle buttons well
that's part of the fun you get better at
it you know that's part you get you get
better at the more you play I can
already see some improvement in you Jim
Blinn the Salone I see the hours you
play this me know like what is the you
said that sick story is like 65 but I
mean I'm sure you can easily do at least
a hundred so it's less than a dollar an
hour oh yeah yeah yeah come on man yeah
you do more than 100 if you just keep
redoing it and go to different places
right and your horse shoot and your
horse the arrow what do you want to just
sit there you could do this is West
world yes yeah this is a saloon from
West world right here are their hookers
and [ __ ] yeah there probably are you
know why there's hookers in West world
that's right so that's a cool little
hallway you like this yeah it's like a
real holy open the doors don't open
yes of course the doors open there's a
guy out of balcony Travis can you do me
a favor shoot that guy in the balcony
let's let's gets it let's get some
action more importantly is there
diversity you know what is there
representation what I see a lot of
representation in this video game Jim
one of the second one of the second
leads I gave is half black half Native
American yep good half but yeah you're
right you're right it made me
uncomfortable to play you know hide
somewhere stupid just what you're up
there why'd you shoot that guy Travis
you asked me to oh geez that could have
been a mistake now you're wanted
so go hide go sit there have a beer
pretend it wasn't you just like that guy
in the shaggy song oh you got a good
[ __ ] seat there oh geez a guy with a
rifle just came up oh wow you punch shot
him you punched his head off
and shot him in the face you put away
the shot man go get a room
hello I'd like to check in no I won't
shoot anybody else Wow go down the steps
Travis all right we should probably take
a break yeah what are you gonna say [ __ ]
low I'm trying to get my attention
yeah there's no hookers you can't buy a
hooker but they said you could buy a
deluxe bath and she can wash you
oh that's nice oh that's a little weird
did you give a hand job under the soap I
don't know maybe hmm
deluxe bath sounds great would you get a
deluxe bath bet I would Jim was just
beginning deluxe bath after deluxe bath
after deluxe bath